bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public 90 minutes
de débats de reportage et d'analyses
comme tous les soirs sur Public Sénat la
promesse et dans le titre vous le savez
donner du sens à l'actualité avec nos
experts vous proposez des clés de
compréhension des mutations de notre
société 90 minutes et l'actu pour
commencer avec la visite d'État du
président français sur le sol européen
suite à l'agression russe contre
l'Ukraine et face aux prises multiples
qui frappe nos nations et nos sociétés
il nous faut savoir
redevenir frère tard l'amitié
franco-américaine pourtant chahuté par
ce plan inflation et climat de Joe Biden
no man de 430 milliards de dollars qui
va évidemment d'abord profiter aux
entreprises
US un protectionnisme dénoncé par
Emmanuel Macron décortique les enjeux
les enjeux de ce séjour à Washington
dans une minute et puis dans trois
quarts d'heure c'est un débat prospectif
que je vous propose sur l'avenir du
conservatisme en France dimanche le
parti LR la République avait désigner
son nouveau président mais sera-t-il
conservateur que signifie ce mot et ce
courant de pensée est-il réservé à la
droite réponse tout à l'heure
mais d'abord donc cette journée
américaine d'Emmanuel Macron résumé par
Flora sauvage
reçu en grande pompe à la Maison Blanche
par Joe Biden et son épouse la première
visite d'État organisée par le président
américain Emmanuel Macron s'est
entretenu avec son homologue dans le
bureau ovale ce matin une visite qui
vient clore la crise de confiance
suscitée par la vente annulée de
sous-marin à l'Australie au profit des
États-Unis l'an dernier
l'autre partenaire inébranlable dans la
cause de la liberté de l'esprit du
marquis de Lafayette qui a contribué au
succès de notre révolution au sacrifice
des g.i Américains qui ont pris d'assaut
les plages de Normandie notre histoire a
été façonnée par le courage des femmes
et des hommes qui ont traversé
l'Atlantique au premier jour de sa
visite d'État pourtant Emmanuel Macron a
déploré les mesures de lutte contre
l'inflation de Joe Biden qu'il juge trop
protectionniste ce plan prévoit plus de
430 milliards de dollars
d'investissement dont 370 milliards pour
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de 40% d'ici à 2030
selon le président français ces
subventions visant à favoriser les
produits made in USA
et qu'on doit se dire entre amis ce
risque c'est que face aux défis que
j'évoque les États-Unis d'Amérique
regardent d'abord les États-Unis
d'Amérique ce qui est normal nous
faisons pareil avec nous regarde ensuite
sa rivalité avec la Chine
et en quelque sorte que l'Europe est
donc la France devient une sorte de
variable d'ajustement un discours franc
et direct attendu par l'administration
américaine après une conférence de
presse commune Emmanuel Macron est
invité ce soir à un dîner de gala
soigneusement calibré pour afficher la
bonne entente entre les deux alliés
et pour ce premier débat de sciences
publiques je vous présente mes invités
Patricia lemonnière bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes grand reporter spécialiste des
relations internationales André Kaspi
bonsoir bienvenue professeur et mérite à
la Sorbonne auteur de nombreux ouvrages
de références sur les États-Unis Stephen
hiver bonsoir vous êtes conseiller
économique à PwC France et Laetitia
cruppa édit politique bonsoir Laetitia
bienvenue à vous alors avant de parler
de ce protectionnisme en quelque sorte
des sujets qui fâchent entre la France
et les États-Unis il y a Patricia le le
décorum le faste d'une visite d'ITA
c'est la première visite d'État
organisée par Joe Biden alors ça
s'explique par la crise covid évidemment
est-ce que c'est quand même un honneur
fait à la France
c'est-à-dire dans l'Europe aujourd'hui
qui qui reste j'ai envie de dire et bien
le Royaume-Uni étant parti l'Allemagne
chancelier est en récent finalement le
seul homme politique qui se dégage
effectivement c'est le président
français et puis on a quand même cette
vieille histoire qui n'est pas si
vieille que ça de langueous derrière qui
a laissé quand même des traces et je
crois de quoi on parle il faut pas être
trop elliptique il faut rappeler cette
histoire des sous-marins que qui ce
fameux contrat presque un contrat du
siècle qui nous est passé sous le nez
que les Américains ont gros refilé au
Britannique et donc les Australiens
pour finir et donc je crois que la
France a été terriblement normal un
fluide choqué par ça et les États-Unis
avaient pratiquement c'était
pratiquement dans les tuyaux aussi le
président a été élu et bien la première
visite pratiquement donné à la France
donc il y avait tout ça derrière
c'est essentiellement ça et que la
visite se déroule dans un face et bien
c'est le type même de visite et je pense
que personne ne me contradira ici
peut-être même de visite que les
Américains font ils font peu de visite à
l'inverse de nous les français qui
adoreront quand même organiser des
visites d'État les Américains c'est pas
leur truc c'est des c'est un vieux
décorum à la limite j'ai envie de dire
c'est visite d'État c'est presque pour
le Vieux Continent un mot que j'aimerais
voir Bani de toutes les langues je suis
fatiguée personnellement de voir qu'on
appelle l'Europe le vieux continent on
va on va le bannir de ce débat alors si
vous voulez bien
André caspi dans l'une de ces
déclarations avant le le la conférence
de presse officielle etc etc Emmanuel
Macron a évoqué le l'histoire commune et
le fait que avec Joe Biden il souhaitait
être à la hauteur de cette de cette
histoire commune et de l'Alliance
franco-américaine on peut peut-être
rapidement dire que il y a des crises il
y en a toujours eu
la naissance des États-Unis a été
nettement favorisé par la France au 18e
siècle on peut remonter au 18e siècle
mais surtout je crois que il faut
mentionner les deux guerres mondiales au
cours de la Première Guerre mondiale les
Américains sont intervenus en 1917 par
1914 et au cours de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale nous savons tous le rôle qu'ils
ont tenu un rôle autrement plus
important que celui de la France et ils
ont participé très largement à la
libération de notre territoire donc si
vous voulez tout cela fait partie de la
mythologie des relations
franco-américaines on leur rappelle cela
de temps à autre pour montrer combien
les Américains sont attachés à la France
combien la France aux États-Unis ça pèse
encore presque 8 décennies après la fin
de la seconde guerre je crois que ça
pèse beaucoup dans les discours
officiels et beaucoup moins dans
l'opinion publique j'ai regardé ce matin
les premières pages du Wall sage et puis
du New York Times je dois dire que je
n'ai pas vu mentionner la visite de
d'Emmanuel Macron alors peut-être que
c'était à l'intérieur du journal mais
cela veut dire quand même que pour les
Américains bon que la France soit
présente très bien pour ceux qui savent
mais je ne pense pas que ce soit leur
préoccupations majeure et nous on va
insister sur le fait que c'est la
première visite d'état d'un chef d'état
depuis Joey bref on a bien compris
Stéphanie alors lors d'une visite d'État
j'y reviens il y a quand même bon là le
président français il est accompagné de
ministre de chefs d'entreprise de
personnalités qui sont triés sur sur le
volet on va parler protectionnisme dans
un instant mais au-delà de ça il y a
est-ce qu'il y a un enjeu business dans
une dans une visite d'État même aux
États-Unis toujours faut voir quand même
les États-Unis restent le premier client
au niveau de l'Union européenne parce
que pour le commerce en fait
Emmanuel Macron en douce le le
de du représentant du commerce de
l'Union européenne donc même si il met
en avant les entreprises françaises donc
il y a quand même un intérêt aussi
d'actualité avec cette cette loi sur la
protection inflation qui déstabilise un
peu l'Union européenne et qui incite en
fait Emmanuel Macron à venir en tant que
chef d'État mais aussi en tant que
représentant de l'Union européenne pour
essayer de faire
alors je pense pas il y aura pas de
d'évolution de de la ligne directrice de
de ce plan mais essayez de faire valoir
un intérêt commun à pas rentrer dans une
dans une guerre économique en fait on y
reviendrait évidemment en détail
Laetitia vous avez analysé les premières
images de de cette journée américaine à
Washington d'Emmanuel Macron alors il y
a évidemment beaucoup de de symboles de
je le rappelle c'est le deuxième
déplacement deuxième visite d'État
d'Emmanuel Macron sur place il y a
beaucoup de symboles il y a beaucoup
d'images qui sont aux populations alors
françaises respectives c'est à dire aux
Français aux Américains mais aussi à la
communauté internationale et puis il y a
aussi des messages qui sont envoyés de
la même façon destinés aux Français et
au monde entier par exemple avant même
que Emmanuel Macron ne rencontre Joe
Biden officiellement il y a quand même
eu ce petit coco Rico alors c'est un
phase c'est une tradition on est
d'accord mais il y a cette ce symbole
français cette hymne national qui
retentit dès l'arrivée du couple Macron
sur le tarmac
[Musique]
évidemment alors je ne pense pas que la
presse américaine en soit complètement
avec vous mais pour les français quand
même voilà le message et là il est fort
c'est une France qui se veut leader de
la jeune Europe
oui devant la Communauté française
Emmanuel Macron a célébré un pilier du
patrimoine français qui vient d'être
inscrit au patrimoine immatériel de
l'humanité la baguette dans ces quelques
centimètres de savoir faire passer
demain en main
il y a il y a exactement l'esprit du
savoir-faire français c'est à dire c'est
quelque chose
d'inhimitable ça paraît être juste
matériel
mais non voilà là aussi c'est du
symbolique à 100% pour les Français mais
pour les Américains qui sont les
premiers en nombre de touristes dans
notre pays alors avant de parler de
l'Ukraine des sujets qui fâchent
finalement de la crise énergétique de
cette affaire des sous-marins oui bah
c'est ces images d'Épinal servent
finalement à poser le décor des rapports
pacifiés et à démontrer finalement cette
amitié franco-française avec dans cette
succession d'images un petit clin d'oeil
posté sur les réseaux sociaux l'accueil
très très chaleureux de Brigitte Macron
à l'école d'art de Washington
[Applaudissements]
c'est le cabinet de la Première Dame
voilà je préfère le rappeler et qui peut
aussi images et bien sûr qu'on a quand
même
on imagine que le modèle de Brigitte
Macron c'est Michel Obama qui reste
encore aujourd'hui la First Lady la plus
populaire en tout cas de vue d'ici là
aussi c'est ça qui est intéressant
soyons soyons précis allez on va rentrer
dans ce qui est quand même l'enjeu
majeur de ce de ce débat et de cette
journée la question du protectionnisme
ce plan vous l'avez évoqué Stéphanie
climat et inflation ça s'appelait une
flèche réduction actes c'est ça le nom
le nom américain qui favorise c'est
logique le made in USA le prise en
français on a parlé alors c'était là
aussi au tout début de cette journée
avant la partie officielle de la visite
qui s'est passé ces derniers mois est un
défi pour nous parce qu'on commence à se
décaler sur les sujets énergétiques et
le coût de la guerre n'est pas le même
en Europe aux États-Unis mais surtout
les choix fait dont je partage les
objectifs en particulier d'une flèche
une réduction actes ou le chips actes
sont des choix qui vont fragmenter
l'Occident parce qu'il crée de telles
différences entre les États-Unis
d'Amérique et l'Europe que pour toutes
celles et ceux qui travaillent dans
nombre d'entreprises ils vont juste se
dire on fait plus d'investissement de
l'autre côté de l'océan
André caspi ce plan c'est une la
palissade mais il faut quand même
l'expliquer il s'adresse d'abord aux
Américains bien entendu et j'ajouterai
une chose c'est que ce plan a été adopté
au mois d'août autrement dit nous sommes
au mois de décembre que je sache ça veut
dire que notre réaction est un peu lente
et que dans un premier temps les
Européens ont plutôt applaudis à ce plan
parce que il y avait une dimension
écologique et que cela correspondait
assez peu aux tendances profondes de la
société américaine mais bon cela dit ce
plan a pour but essentiellement de
réduire l'inflation et surtout de
prendre parti contre le réchauffement
climatique alors c'est un plan qui
correspond comme vous l'avez dit aux
environs de 400 millions de dollars mais
ça veut dire quand même que c'est
excusez-moi c'est pas des millions c'est
des milliards 400 milliards de dollars
donc c'est un plan très important mais
c'est un plan en somme qui s'adresse
tout particulièrement aux Américains
aujourd'hui parce que nous sommes au
lendemain des élections de mi-mandat ces
élections de mi-mandat Joe Biden les a
ne les a pas perdus mais enfin disons
qu'il les a gagné et que les États-Unis
entrent désormais dans le dans la
campagne pour les présidentielles de
2024 par conséquentes
qui est très importante et Joe Biden qui
a déclaré qu'il se représentait aux
personnes ne le croit mais enfin sauf
lui peut-être mais en tout état de cause
ça veut dire que il a intérêt à flatter
son électorat son électorat démocrate et
il a intérêt aussi par cette déclaration
à éviter dès maintenant une bataille au
sein du parti démocrate donc il faut pas
négliger le côté politique les
conséquences politiques de cette mesure
qui a été adoptée il y a quelques mois
Stéphanie est-ce que Emmanuel Macron
vous l'avez un peu évoqué mais c'est une
micro chance qu'il obtienne des
dérogations parce que ça peut être ça il
y a des jets déjà eu des dérogations
pour d'autres pays je crois le Mexique
et le Canada si je ne me trompe est-ce
que l'Europe et la France peut peuvent
en espérer d'autres alors déjà ce qu'il
faut ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'on a
une balance commerciale
ultra excédentaire je parle de l'Europe
vis-à-vis des États-Unis donc les
États-Unis ils sont droits dans leur
bottes ils ont pas ils se disent ils
sont pas obligés de d'aider le commerce
européen parce que ça marche déjà très
bien
ensuite ce qui ce qu'il faut comprendre
en fait l'Europe craint ne crains pas
véritablement son ce plan mais les
effets de ce plan parce que de plus en
plus de grands groupes européens se
disent que la facture énergétique est
trop élevée en Europe quelques ça sera
une facture énergétique élevée et
durable étant donné que même si on se on
trouve d'autres fournisseurs pour
remplacer la Russie et même si on va
vers les énergies propres c'est toujours
des des coûts de production plus élevés
et donc en c'est le double effet qui qui
s'ajoute parce que les grands groupes se
disent en plus on va si on va
directement produire sur place aux
États-Unis on aura tous ces avantages
sous forme de subventions donc l'Europe
se retrouve dans une situation où elle
voit déjà qu'il y a un risque de
délocalisation qui risque d'être
amplifié par par ce plan et vous avez
raison en fait il réagissent un peu tard
c'est c'est ils prennent la mesure
l'ampleur du de ce phénomène un peu tard
avec les risques pourquoi pour bien
comprendre pourquoi il y a d'abord eu
une un sentiment positif pourquoi la
première réaction à l'annonce de ce plan
c'est se dire très bien parce que parce
que l'Europe est engagée dans la
transition la transformation écologique
et que on était satisfait que les
États-Unis en braille c'est ça voilà et
puis il y avait pas le dans l'esprit des
Européens il y avait pas encore ce
risque de mouvement de délocalisation de
certains grands groupes européens et
cette menace où la on prend ça
clairement au sérieux même si c'est pas
encore fait mais bon ça c'est encore un
autre débat mais cette menace existe
Patricia lemonnière dans l'attitude
d'Emmanuel Macron on l'a déjà évoqué
mais moi j'ai un peu le sentiment de
session de rattrapage parce que il y a
eu la présidence tournante de l'Union
européenne mais bon qui a été finalement
tous les événements qui étaient prévus
ont dû être annulés notamment à cause de
la de la guerre en Irak et de la guerre
en c'est drôle c'est pas la première
fois que je fais ce ce lapsus c'est
générationnel excusez-moi bref donc vous
savez ce qu'elle garde de quelle guerre
je veux parler en Ukraine évidemment
mais ça ça a quand même chamboulé tous
les espoirs qui Emmanuel enfin j'ai
sentiments là qu'Emmanuel Macron mettait
dans cette présence tournante est-ce que
il y a eu un côté session de rattrapage
pour vous dans cette dans cette visite
là il est sûr qu'il se présente aussi
comme comme vous l'avez dit comme le
chef en quelque sorte de la Communauté
européenne mais ce discours aussi je
crois est à est en effet en direction
des Européens vous savez sur toute cette
question de
économique en fait qui qui n'est pas
récente comme vous le disiez avec les
États-Unis on a de multiples exemples
depuis des années britanniquement depuis
Nixon et Reagan si on remonte loin ça ne
ça on a cessé de s'affronter l'Europe
n'a jamais considéré que le chant
économique était un champ de guerre
c'est pas dans c'est pas trop dans les
mentalités ça commence un peu à venir ça
commence légèrement à changer et
Emmanuel Macron lui aussi change de
logiciel vis-à-vis de cette réalité de
ce combat économique parce que avril il
était plutôt comme tout le monde un peu
pour les échanges qui font
prospérer la paix en quelque sorte les
chantres de cette théorie étant les
Allemands et là en ce moment et bien
avec justement ce risque de
délocalisation aussi l'énergie que quand
même les Américains nous vendent leur
gage je crois 10 fois plus cher qu'il ne
le paye chez eux je vais dire là vous
voyez c'est aussi on en prend plein
plein respirent en quelque sorte plein
plein le nez en quelque sorte et bien si
vous voulez sur toutes ces questions
Emmanuel Macron est en train d'entraîner
son partenaire allemand dans cette entre
guillemets rhétorique de qu'il faudrait
effectivement peut-être construire
quelque chose pour défendre l'Europe par
rapport aux agressions économiques il
n'y a pas que la les États-Unis il y a
la Chine aussi évidemment on va parler
de la Chine est-ce que parce qu'on
entend assez souvent ce discours ici
est-ce que les États-Unis
je mets plein de guillemets mais mes
profites économiquement de la guerre en
Ukraine est-ce qu'elle favorise plus
l'économie américaine que l'économie
européenne je pense que l'aide que les
États-Unis fournissent à l'Ukraine est
une aide considérable bien sûr qui est
aux environs de 100 milliards donc ça
veut dire que ils sont quand même les
principaux fournisseurs de cette aide il
joue un rôle capital et du même coup il
montre à l'Europe qu'elle n'est pas tout
à fait à la même hauteur et puis en ce
qui concerne la fameuse mesure du mois
d'août je crois qu'il faut ajouter que
chaque famille américaine qui achète une
voiture américaine recevoir
éventuellement 7500 dollars à condition
que la voiture américaine
comporte des batteries fabriquées aux
États-Unis c'est la mesure
protectionniste et il est évident que
fabriqué des batteries aux États-Unis
c'est favoriser les ouvriers qui
travaillent dans ces entreprises ces
ouvriers sont syndiqués et par
conséquent ils font partie de la
clientèle démocrate voilà en somme si
vous voulez le contenu de toutes ces
mesures qui sont à la fois économiques
écologiques et politiques si on parle
bien ce focus sur le secteur des
batteries parce que là l'Europe aussi
est en train d'essayer de créer sa
filière de batterie électrique pour ne
plus être dépendant de des pays
asiatiques et notamment de la Chine là
on est dans un dans une course contre
contre est-ce qu'on peut dire ça dans
plus généralement dans cette
transformation environnementale
on met jamais autant que les les
Etats-Unis c'est on est toujours en
retard là on a réussi un seul plan de
relance depuis notre histoire ce qui est
très bien le
plan de 350 milliards qui a été mais bon
ça n'a rien à voir avec
en face ce qui est capable d'être alloué
par les États-Unis donc on joue pas dans
la même cour parce que là on retrouve le
même problème que le niveau l'Europe la
façon dont l'Europe est constituée
c'est-à-dire on parle d'une seule voix
pour le commerce international mais
quand même en interne on préfère
défendre son économie nationale donc on
n'arrive pas à mutualiser nos moyens
pour notamment aller dans la recherche
mettre les moyens c'est aussi valable
pour les semi-conducteurs enfin on c'est
jamais à la même échelle en fait
il y a aussi un plan semi-conducteur
c'est ça qui avait été annoncé par par
Joe Biden
on sait très bien qu'il faut qu'on
trouve on sait très bien qu'il est
nécessaire de trouver une solution c'est
à dire que là c'est lié aussi au
problème de Taïwan c'est-à-dire qu'au
fond c'est Taïwan qui produit
l'essentiel des semis conducteurs et par
conséquent protéger Taiwan c'est aussi
protégé le marché des semis conducteurs
et alors les États-Unis cherchent à se
dégager de cette dépendance ils n'y sont
pas encore arrivés donc Taïwan reste
quand même à la tête de cette production
alors cette visite d'État du président
français elle est forcément critiquée
par un certain nombre de représentants
de l'opposition ici à Paris notamment le
rassemblement national par la voie de
son porte-parole qui était ce matin sur
notre antenne
Macron c'est l'éternel en même temps je
veux dire les États-Unis sont des amis
de la France historiquement mais ils
sont aussi parfois des concurrents et
ils sont aussi parfois sur certains
enjeux économiques des adversaires donc
on doit pouvoir entretenir avec les
États-Unis une relation qui soit
exigeante on dirait qu'Emmanuel Macron
le découvre quand les Américains font du
patriotisme économique ils défendent
leurs intérêts moi ça m'énerve si nous
en sommes victimes mais moi j'aimerais
que non mais moi j'aimerais qu'on
défende nos intérêts qu'on fasse nous du
patriotisme économique on voit bien que
les États-Unis sont en train de profiter
de cette guerre de ce conflit armé en
Ukraine qui économiquement ce sont eux
qui en profitent mais nous l'avions dit
dès le début donc Emmanuel Macron un peu
le côté ce côté un peu naïf on dirait
Bécassine aux Etats-Unis enfin
sincèrement il découvre la poudre voilà
démonstration pour arriver à cette
phrase qui qui frappe est d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a reprise
Bécassine aux États-Unis bref on est
peut-être tombé dans le piège de la
communication politique un petit peu
allez on va on va le procès en naïveté
quand même et c'est pas intéressant
c’est aussi pour ça qu'on a choisi cet
extrait de Sébastien Chenu ce matin face
à rien de Mancini c'est Fanny je reste
avec vous parce que c'est vrai que la
Chine aux États-Unis ont pas peur de
prendre des mesures protectionnistes
c'est pas la première fois
l'Europe l'Union européenne a peut-être
un presque un est-ce qu'on pourrait dire
presque un blocage
philosophique ou idéologique à le faire
on s'est construit autour l'Union
européenne s'est construit autour du
libre-échange ça fait partie de notre
ADN c'est compliqué après de de dire que
bah c'est pas dans tous les cas et on
considère l'Europe se dit que plus il y
aura de libre-échange comme vous l'avez
dit on préambule la croissance sera
préservée et il y aura moins de conflits
armés voilà cette année ça a peut-être
pas nous a peut-être montré un autre
exemple mais et donc c'est c'est
difficile de revenir sur sur cette sur
ce ce principe même de construction de
l'Union européenne parce que au sein
même de l'Union européenne il vous êtes
libre circulation qui va qui va très
loin c'est pas uniquement des
marchandises c'est aussi des hommes des
capitaux et ça fonctionne très bien je
parle au niveau économique la croissance
est assurée par un commerce qui qui
circule et qui se développe au sein de
cette zone de libre-échange donc on nous
on a l'impression nous Européens que
c'est cette ce principe là qu'il faut
diffuser mais pour diffuser ce principe
et pour que ça marche il faut être deux
Stark si on est tout seul à vouloir le
libre-échange c'est on c'est nous les
perdants voilà et donc Patricia Lemaire
on voit quand même il y a cette idée de
taxe carbone aux frontières de l'Europe
enfin c'est ce sont des des idées des
projets qui qui avancent au niveau
européen de alors peut-être pas à ce
niveau de protectionnisme mais bon c'est
dans les tuyaux oui il y a des
discussions je dirais plutôt que ça
avance parce que il y a des oppositions
très fortes dans l'Europe mais vous
savez que pour faire avancer l'Europe
jusqu'à présent c'est quand même il faut
que tout le monde soit d'accord il
faudrait ou alors il faut changer les
règles et on a des pays des blocs de
pays qui sont opposés qui sont farruches
qui ne veulent pas pour des raisons soit
eux-mêmes de commerce ou soit que pour
des raisons idéologiques ils ne veulent
pas changer de ce que j'appelle de
mantra pratiquement sur ces questions là
donc effectivement la France vous dit en
ce moment bouge sur ces questions avec
les États-Unis il y a plusieurs idées
qui ont été avancées faire entre
l'équivalent
américain faire un Fond européen
se retourner vers l'OMC pour faire
pression comme on avait fait pression
pour la guerre entre Boeing et Airbus
c'était l'OMC arbitrer tout ça
l'organisation du commerce mondial enfin
je pense que tout le monde sait et donc
il y a plusieurs options mais là encore
on s'y prend très tard enfin comme vous
le dites on se réveille avec des moines
sur toutes les questions
l'Europe est très procédurière va
lentement ça prend un temps fou c'est
pour ça que les Américains nous prennent
pas au sérieux souvent ce qui se disent
avec eux bon bah dans trois ans on aura
la réponse quoi en quelque sorte les
gens ils ont ce regard un peu
condescendant je vous l'accorde mais qui
est aussi réel on a eu des procédures en
Europe qui sont inadmissibles ne
serait-ce que ce que pour par exemple
tout ce qui est semi-conducteurs on veut
lancer des choses mais attendez avant
que ça soit lancé on sera envahi par
tout le monde c'est pas qu'une question
financière mais André Caspian on
l'évoquait tout à l'heure vu la quantité
de produits que l'Europe exporte vers
les États-Unis est-ce qu'il y a pas plus
de risques à rentrer dans un bras de fer
protectionnisme pour l'Europe finalement
oui mais enfin disons que ce bras de fer
comportera des nuances et que
l'essentiel c'est quand même de
maintenir cette supériorité des
exportations sur les importations ceux
qui choque simplement en Europe c'est le
prix du gaz américain c'est à dire qu'au
fond ça c'est un handicap tout
particulier qui est relativement récent
et qui montre que l'Europe a besoin des
États-Unis et les États-Unis le savent
bien évidemment donc ils sont si on peut
dire ils ont ils dispose à ce moment-là
de la haute main sur les décisions
européennes et sans compter que euh
l'aide massive qu'ils accordent à
l'Ukraine montre que sans eux il n'y
aurait pas de résistance à la Russie ça
serait impossible donc ça veut dire que
pour les Américains il faut combattre
bien sûr les Russes quand ils commettent
des agressions mais l'essentiel de
l'essentiel de l'essentiel c'est quand
même la guerre sous toutes ses formes
sauf militaires contre la Chine et
est-ce que ça veut dire pardon nous
interrompre que le le centre de gravité
de la diplomatie américaine et
clairement tournée vers la Chine
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que pas au
point de tourner le dos à l'Europe mais
est-ce qu'on peut parler j'ai pas
d'obsession chinoise faites un peu
caricaturale si je dis ça mais non c'est
pas une obsession c'est une réalité elle
a la réalité c'est un conflit sous
toutes ses formes entre les États-Unis
et la Chine mais un conflit qui
heureusement n'a pas encore pris un
aspect militaire donc c'est un conflit
économique c'est un conflit commercial
c'est un conflit idéologique les Chinois
n'agissent pas comme les Russes ils ne
font pas immédiatement une agression
contre un territoire ils sont plus
astucieux que les Russes donc ils
attendent mais ils savaient également
que il disposent d'une puissance
commerciale qui est considérable alors
aujourd'hui elle est un peu affaiblie
par les conséquences du covid et par
l'agitation qui semble-t-il règne en
Chine mais il n'empêche que pour les
Américains ce qui reste valable c'est
que dans les années à venir c'est contre
la Chine qu'ils doivent agir sous toutes
ses formes mais ça rejoint à Stéphanie
une des déclarations d'Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui qu'on a diffusé tout à
l'heure le risque finalement de dans ce
bras de fer un peu protectionniste que
ça fragmente l'Union occidentale et la
fin de la phrase elle était tellement
sous-entendue qu'on peut la faire face à
la Chine oui bien sûr il voudrait mieux
unir nos forces mais je pense que les
États ne crois pas en la réactivité de
l'Europe donc elle agit ils agissent
seuls en se disant que de toute manière
l'Europe arrivera derrière pour pour
essayer de renfort mais en tout cas
c'est souvent une tendance des
États-Unis le seul voilà ils sont
habitués et
ils n'entendent pas à mettre l'Europe
dans dans les négociations avec la Chine
mais est-ce que ce n'est pas aller un
peu trop vite pardon c'est une question
de positionner les États-Unis face à la
Chine comme guerre primordiale en
laissant un second plan la Russie alors
qu'il y a la guerre en Ukraine en ce
moment enfin il me semble que les
États-Unis sont à la fois en guerre
contre la Russie d'une certaine manière
et contre la Chine mais c'est pas la
même guerre non c'est pas la même guerre
du tout c'est à dire contre la Russie
c'est parce que la Russie a agressé
l'Ukraine mais contre la Chine la Chine
n'a pas encore agressé Taïwan non mais
c'est une guerre commerciale une guerre
commerciale c'est une guerre éc c'est
une guerre idéologique dans certaines
régions du monde c'est une guerre en
somme qui reste dans le domaine
politique mais qui n'a pas encore revêtu
un aspect de force on en est encore si
vous voulez à la bagarre entre entre la
Russie
quel est l'idéologie de la Russie moi
j'aimerais savoir et puis si c'était
s'il n'avait rien fait sur l'Ukraine de
toute façon c'était la porte ouverte à
Taïwan bah il y avait une nécessité
d'intervenir sur l'Ukraine pour les
États-Unis parce que s'il laissait faire
ma foi la Chine c'était un message
indirect envoyé
les Chinois ont regardé de très près en
Ukraine bien sûr alors on va revenir au
cœur de cette visite d'État et à la
présence d'Emmanuel Macron à Washington
on a on a vu quelques images grâce à
vous Laetitia on va revenir remonter un
peu le temps grâce à table être à nuit
qui est juste derrière le rideau de sens
public bonsoir oui oui on revient avec
vous sur les les relations d'Emmanuel
Macron avec les présidents américains
oui on va regarder quelques images
effectivement et les premières images
marquantes que j'ai retrouvé bien c'est
un coup de fil un coup de fil qui ne
sert à rien mais un coup de fil qui pète
sur le CV du jeune candidat Emmanuel
Macron avec celui qui n'est plus
président déjà depuis quelques mois mais
qui est qui était et qui est l'un des
hommes les plus cools de la planète j'ai
nommé Barack Obama nous sommes en avril
2017 regardez et écoutez
voilà on est d'accord il se dit à peu
près rien dans cet échange que laisse
opportunément diffusé bien sûr les
équipes du candidat Macron et surtout ce
n'est pas un soutien officiel nous
précistons à l'époque mais quelques
semaines plus tard et bien le coup de
fil apporté ses fruits regardez cette
allocution de Barack Obama
alors quels sont les images qui sont
restées d'Emmanuel Macron avec le
successeur de Barack Obama Donald Trump
alors là ce sont des relations plus
complexes un des montagnes russes côté
bas de la montagne un juin 2017 Donald
Trump retire les États-Unis de l'accord
de Paris voici la réponse d'Emmanuel
Macron qu'on a tous en mémoire bien sûr
make en planète
et un mois plus tard et bien on est en
haut de la montagne 14 juillet 2017 et
oui ça va vite Donald Trump a reçu en
grande pompe à Emmanuel Macron c'est une
visite officielle et voilà en lui
déroule le tapis rouge réception aux
Invalides défilé du 14 juillet dont
Donald Trump est l'invité d'honneur car
en fait le centenaire de l'entrée en
guerre des États-Unis dans la première
guerre mondiale et enfin et bien il y a
aussi un dîner d'amis à la Tour Eiffel
rien que ça voilà où ils sont reçus par
Alain Ducasse en personne on met les
petits plats dans les grands et on met
en sourdine les désaccords climatiques
et de cette période on retient des
images de grandes familiarité avril 2018
c'est là romance comme disent les
Américains avec à l'occasion de la
visite des Macron aux États-Unis il y a
même une catégorie quand vous regardez
dans les images de l'Agence France
Presse les deux hommes multiplient les
gestes d'affection d'accolade des
regards complices et des scènes un petit
peu étranges il faut bien le dire la
réalité c'est que en revanche en
coulisses et bien il s'oppose sur
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien et
puis quelques mois plus tard c'est
carrément et bien à la gare ouverte le
c'est pourtant le 11 novembre 2018
Emmanuel Macron commémore l'armistice
mais ces mots sont reçus comme une
déclaration de guerre par les équipes de
Donald Trump car le patriotisme
et l'exacte contraire du nationalisme
le nationalisme en est la trahison
voilà en résumé une relation complexe
marquée par de lourds conflits et des
accords derrière de belles images qui
ont fait le bonheur des photographes et
des réseaux sociaux et des journalistes
pour conclure je ne résiste pas à vous
remontrer les images de la très longue
poignée de main entre Donald Trump et
Emmanuel Macron voilà regardez c'est
long c'est long c'est long qu'est-ce
qu'on a pu gloser sur ce qui avait gagné
ce bras de fer ou plutôt cette bataille
de pouce
calculé combien de secondes ça ça durait
regarder les phalanges des uns et des
autres bref c'était parfaitement
Emmanuel Macron parce que c'est
Donald Trump qui avait l'habitude de
donner cette moyennement très viril très
ferme et donc il s’était entraîné et
c'était à celui qui lâcherait le premier
Patricia Lemonnier bon elles sont assez
ridicule ces images quand on les revoit
aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est forcément plus facile
avec un jobiden c'est c'est parce que là
on caricature parfois
la présidence Trump mais finalement
est-ce qu'il y a pas une forme de
continuité aussi entre les deux
présidents américains dans les relations
avec la France ou l'Europe il y a deux
choses d'abord on a une énorme attente
vis-à-vis de Joe Biden je crois en
Europe mais aussi en France on a cru
qu'avec lui ça allait être enfin des
relations apaisées formidables etc on a
mis du temps et on a légèrement déchanté
parce que quand c'est aperçu que
l'Amérique reste Amérique et son intérêt
propre passe en premier et après et bien
effectivement la petite Europe le Vieux
Continent et ça ça n'a pas changé je
crois les relations sont différentes
plus apaisées plus courtoises en plus
les anciennes équipes au niveau
diplomatique économique connaissaient
les équipes Obama donc par derrière il y
a des relations qui sont franchement
beaucoup plus cordiales et constructive
quant aux deux présidents qui sont
beaucoup dans la représentation et
chaque fois un peu dans le chaud il faut
l'admettre et bien quand deux présidents
ils poursuivent tout le tout de leur
intérêt Emmanuel veut se présenter comme
l'homme de l'Europe il a maintenant j'ai
l'impression des il sort du champ de la
France qui tape plus s'en occuper il
s'occupe de l'Europe et Joe Biden lui
défend son Amérique face à la Chine face
à la Russie et il n'en démordera pas
parce qu'effectivement comme vous le
faites très bien remarqué et bien il y a
un enjeu politique c'est les élections
André caspillet quelles sont les
différents
les différents majeures en termes
diplomatiques entre un Donald Trump et
un Joe Biden depuis 2 ans qu'il est
qu'il est à la Maison Blanche je crois
d'abord il y a la méthode c'est à dire
qu'au fond Trump est beaucoup plus
brutal et Joe byden essaye si vous
voulez
de ménager la chèvre et le chou donc ça
ce sont les méthodes qui sont
différentes les personnels et c'est
également sont différents puisque comme
on voulait on la souligner
Joe Biden s'est entouré de personnels
qui ont déjà travaillé souvent avec
Barack Obama c'est c'est la suite alors
quant à Joe Biden lui-même
je vous dirais que
il navigue un peu au gré des vents mais
il sait bien sûr qu'il doit défendre les
intérêts des États-Unis et plus
particulièrement les intérêts de son
parti il est dans une situation
difficile à définir mais si vous voulez
il n'a pas cette brutalité dans dans
l'action dans la présentation que
pouvait avoir Donald Trump en imagine
pas par exemple Joe Biden tenant la main
de Emmanuel Macron pendant 20 secondes
sans vouloir la lâcher c'est pas son
genre puis d'ailleurs ça lui ferait mal
donc
je crois que
il y a des différences si vous voulez
dans la forme mais sur le fond je vois
pas tellement où sont les différences et
si on prend par exemple le cas de
l'accord avec l'Iran bon c'est vrai que
Joe Biden a essayé de raccommoder les
relations entre les aux États-Unis et
puis l'Iran en particulier par ce plan
qui rassemble plusieurs nations dont la
France d'ailleurs mais finalement il
s'est aperçu que avec l'Iran bon ça ne
marche pas et puis n'oubliez pas que Joe
Biden traîne derrière lui la débordade
de Caboul qui elle date du mois d'août
2021 c'est-à-dire quand même de Trump
c'est Trump qui a fait l'accord
des Américains ont fui donc c'est si
vous voulez c'est ça montre dans un
certain sens que la brutalité de Donald
Trump pour nous la retrouve pas chez Joe
Biden et par conséquent ce sont quand
même de mentalités de deux attitudes qui
sont vraiment différentes l'une de
l'autre alors on a déjà évoqué mais
rapidement le la question de la guerre
en Ukraine Laetitia sur ce terrain aussi
la visite du président français elle est
assez riche de de symboles alors ils
sont d'abord détaché évidemment au passé
et à la Seconde Guerre mondiale oui
parce que vous avez vous dire Monsieur
que ce n'est pas encore dans les
opinions publiques c'est la seconde
guerre mondiale est oubliée etc il me
semble pas il me semble pas parce qu'à
chaque visite d'État l'une des premières
visites et l'un des premiers de
n'importe quel président français c'est
d'aller se recueillir auprès des anciens
combattants et là dès son arrivée
Emmanuel Macron est allé se recueillir
au cimetière national Darlington où
repose les anciens combattants
américains il a tweeté immédiatement
tant étant de héros sont tombés pour
libérer la France c'est le passage
obligé pour chaque visite d'État alors
ça appartient peut-être la mythologie
française mais en tout cas c'est ça
marque les opinions publiques cette
amitié franco-américaine la France a
jamais redevable finalement des
États-Unis qu'il a sauvé du jour nazi et
là encore les deux pays ont diffusé les
mêmes images ces images de rencontre
aussi des manuels Macron avec les
anciens combattants qui sont encore en
vie et c'est important ces images là
regardez
nous vous faisons chevalier de la Légion
d'honneur
peut pas croire que ça ne marque pas les
Américains elles sont précieux ces
images parce que c'est messieurs sont
encore là et seront bientôt parti et
malheureusement oui mais bon ce sont des
images qui sont envoyées aussi pourquoi
pour préparer justement
l'alignement de des États-Unis et de la
France pour la politique avoir sur la
guerre de la guerre en Ukraine
effectivement qu'est-ce qu'on peut en
dire ce soir France et États-Unis se
travaille étroitement et de façon
alignée on a l'impression que sur par
exemple l'arrêt de la guerre en Ukraine
ils sont d'accord pour que ça n'a pas
passe par des négociations et je fais le
pari aussi que avant cela on va enterrer
la hache de guerre définitivement de ce
contrat du siècle perdu à cause des
États-Unis on va voir un Joe Biden et un
Emmanuel Macron très proche pourquoi
pour dire c'est fini le coup dans le dos
comme l'avait dit Jean-Yves Le Drian
c'est du passé et maintenant nous sommes
sur la même position sur la même et
d'accord pour qu'il y ait des
négociations pour sortir une fois pour
toute de sa guerre ou Ukraine André
caspi sur la guerre en Ukraine la
stratégie américaine sur le conflit vous
nous avez rappelé le la somme enfin les
dizaines et dizaines de milliards de
dollars qui ont déjà été dépensés est-ce
que cette stratégie elle est en train
d'évoluer alors un peu c'est à dire que
je pense que dans l'opinion américaine
la guerre en Ukraine n'a pas eu le même
poids que dans l'opinion européenne ne
serait-ce que par les résistance et puis
aussi parce que beaucoup d'Américains ne
sont pas d'origine européenne on oublie
par exemple que les Hispaniques forment
20 à 25% de la population et qu'il y a
des asiatiques comme disent les
Américains des asiatiques qui sont pas
uniquement des Chinois ou des Japonais
mais qui peuvent être aussi des
Philippins des Indiens etc qui
représentent 7 à 8% de la population ça
veut donc dire que plus du quart de la
population américaine
est loin de des affaires européennes et
puis il faut dire aussi que il y a une
certaine fatigue de la part de l'opinion
américaine à entendre parler de
l'Ukraine ajouté à cela que désormais la
Chambre des Représentants est à majorité
républicaine de peu de très peu mais il
n'empêche que les républicains sont eux
aussi beaucoup moins favorables à la
continuité de cette aide que ne l'était
les démocrates mais le temps passe c'est
à dire qu'au fond maintenant depuis le
24 février
l'eau a coulé sous l'épon de Washington
et par conséquent ça veut dire que il y
a une certaine lassitude mais donc quoi
essayer de trouver un chemin de
négociation sur la négociation par la
négociation parce qu'on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça surtout avec la
perspective de l'entrée en hiver qui
sera particulièrement rude dans ces
régions là et qui nécessitera sans aucun
doute un surcroît de l'aide américaine
Patricia lemonière oui je crois aussi
qu'il y a une autre raison si vous
voulez tout le monde s'accorde pour dire
effectivement c'est le président
Zelinski qui choisira et puis on a vu
monter cette petite musique temps
politique militaire chef d'état-major
américain a dit qu'un jour ou l'autre
grosso modo il faudrait bien se mettre
autour de la table je crois que les
États-Unis ont un problème très simple
c'est que l'effort de guerre colossale
qu'il fournissent mais c'est qu'un jour
ils ont ils ont les militaires vont être
obligés et ont déjà commencé à puiser
dans leur stock stratégique et ça ils ne
veulent pas en entendre parler parce que
si jamais un jour Biden leur dit écoutez
là il nous faut encore des canons ou des
choses comme ça mais non non l'industrie
américaine
a de la difficulté à fournir et on est
sur certaines types d'armement au bord
de taper dans les stocks stratégiques et
franchement ça les militaires américains
ils ne veulent pas en entendre parler
donc ceux qui sont finalement le plus
pour la paix aujourd'hui ce sont les
militaires américains qui tentent de de
faire comprendre à leur président que la
guerre c'est bien mais faudrait
peut-être pas qu'elle dure longtemps et
une dernière chose on dit que la France
était alignée sur les positions
américaines la France veut essayer de se
montrer comme un faiseur de paix c'est
une chose et c'est des Américains qui
sonneront à la fin de la partie parce
que c'est eux qui ne le décideront merci
beaucoup vous voulez dire un dernier mot
non je voulais simplement dire que en
plus les militaires pensent à Taïwan oui
on y revient donc
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vous dis à
bientôt évidemment sur public